rebel wilson's fitness journey i mean is
still going so strong in fact
she revealed that because of her
changing her diet and her fitness
routine she has dropped
40 pounds this year and she recently
revealed the fans on the drew barrymore
show
not only about her successful weight
loss journey but the fun way she kind of
figured out how to bring on new
challenges like this take a listen
so the last few years i've been like
theming my years
so i had like the year of fun last year
i had the year of love
and then this year i'm like it's going
to be the year of health
because i turned 40 um this year in
march
and i never really focused on my health
which was probably obvious
um i was going all around the world jet
setting everywhere and
eating a ton of sugar that was kind of
my advice like i have a very sweet tooth
i love
desserts i think calling out a specific
year of your life as
a themed goal like a specific goal to
achieve
is really an interesting approach uh
what do you think of that now is there a
specific way you kind of set
your intentions or goals in your life
that works well for you
i'm actually gonna take a cue from rebel
because i feel like once you say
okay this year is going to be a theme
you don't get caught up
on the little ups and downs that happen
throughout the year right because she
said this is a year of health
so that means healthy relationships that
means healthy eating that's health all
around
and what i find is when i make goals
especially when they're specific
it's great to do that but i find that
so much more happens that year that i
couldn't even have expected
so it's also great to leave space open
for things that you couldn't have even
imagined to happen so that's why i'm
with this theme
this theme idea i love that but
something that i would take is just
don't i feel like less is more when it
comes to goals at times it's better to
have
focused clear goals instead of 50 and
you know you're all over the place
trying to make them happen
give your spa give yourself the space
and time to achieve those goals you have
a whole year to do it so just focus on
one thing
i'm taking a cue from level two uh so
maybe next year will be the year of
health for me
we'll have to wait and find out